former italian interior minister and
deputy prime minister matteo salvini
has been ordered to stand trial the
right-wing league party leader
has been charged with kidnapping in a
case involving a ship
carrying refugees and migrants in 2019
let's go live now to our cheers
rory challenge who's in london rory tell
us more about this
yeah there are two very similar uh cases
currently open
against salvini and they both
relate to very similar events where
ships were held off the coast of italy
back in 2019 the summer of 2019
now one of them was a spanish
ngo ship called the open arms
and the other was an italian coast guard
ship called the gregoretti
both of them held many many
migrants who'd been rescued out at sea
and
under salvini's uh government or the
government that salvini was a part of at
the time
those ships were basically kept off the
coast of
uh the italian coastline
while his governments basically tried to
get
europe uh to take more of these
immigrants and
share the burden of uh immigrants within
the european union now
uh the open arms ship the spanish
ngoship that's the one where the judge
has said that yes this there is a case
for salvini to
answer and that this should go toward to
trial a week ago
in the other one the gregoretti a
prosecutor a state prosecutor said
actually no
there isn't a case to answer and this
shouldn't go towards trial
that has yet to be uh ruled on by a
judge
uh to decide whether it will or not go
to trial and that will happen
in a few weeks time now salvini himself
has said that at the time
he was only doing what was in italy's
national
interest uh and that uh this imperative
to get
european countries to share more of the
immigrant burden
was uh something that he would do again
you know he
he says he's not repentant or regretful
of this
he says that at the time he was
basically endeavoring to restore
italy's dignity and its sovereignty
life there in london rory many thanks
indeed